really grow long I was born in Hollywood
and I was raised up in thank leaky right
because I mean San Bernardino Mountains
I don't remember most of it because I
was torturing myself invited oh why did
you were tortured and molested from a
very young age up to about 16 so my
father stepfather any separately of
course yeah separately all different
kind of it you know my stepfather he
used to do things and it put me in the
trunk of a car too scary or and for me
up in a sofa bed so that just to
terrified me so I wouldn't say anything
and I didn't remember what my father did
I always put I put all of those on to my
grounds and my stepfather everything was
on my stepfather until I got older and
and I started to to come to the
realization there there was there was oh
yeah you know and they gonna I had
really bad PTSD do the effects my
stepfather so they were doing this like
little study I'm here whatever and they
found that this they would you know take
me back to to those times and finally
one of the psychiatrist says enough is
enough so we get her back there then
what then what then she's just rehashing
it reliving it and then we sent her on
home and we go to dinner and have some
drinks at the bar and she's a mess so he
said why we do is I want you to sit down
and I want you to to imagine that those
people that did those horrible things to
you we're now in the same situation you
were with them something horrible was
happening to them and their children
because you see nobody just wakes up and
says they're gonna torture molest
children some kind of strange mental
twist happens to them and from that
point forward they start to have this
need to do these days they're there
so I imagine there's little kids things
happening to them and I was able to like
they go on the Adrian because only I
suffered from hey did you know what's
going on their leg off on their life
ever
oh I was right graduated from sixteen
sixteen you to move to the big scene
right so I just I left you know my left
and hit the streets is like so after
that I got a dad's died of those dead
John those type of dance clubs dining
eyes closed and stripping and stuff like
that and I started dealing and a bigger
deal bigger connection so I semi tell me
that did actually mother was at
Alexandria Hotel downtown and I can get
a big connection there so back in the
day everybody was kind of thinking so I
went out of this hotel they run in the
room and meeting and getting involved
with it make some money aside well you
clearly
yeah ah the girls in the dance club
oh and you're using crack-cocaine yeah
that's my medication yeah I had a
psychiatrist tell me one time if I keep
prescribed you crack I would do that can
you see this just to work for me
you everybody else who smokes it it's
kind of tweaking and and skinny and when
I smoke I've called it and you do for
money you examination done they tricks
my body you've had some experiences yeah
if should I break for stereo cameras
you survived for certain things
yeah but some people first I understand
this they're not far and few between
serial killers are not far in future
there's thousands of them thousands of
them right here right now in Los Angeles
yeah and they come to this neighborhood
because the girls are dispensable they
feel right and hey and the thing is just
that I know that when someone picks me
up to do something foul
they've done it many times before
because I would not be my first choice
and trying to do something like that I
get some key frail timid timid little
girl I wouldn't get one that I thought I
could fight me back and so laggy scared
my brain goes fight fight fight fight
fight because yourself do it if you bite
scratch kid you know whatever gouge out
eyes spread by the throat or anything I
said people when they get scared please
okay yeah I I was actually in the hotel
over by Alvarado area and was a customer
and I check out for you'll get some
crack and on my way back his man stops
me in this gold Honda he was he was jet
it was Korean but he was like 62 or 63
he was not stocky but really
athletically claimed he was really cut
it's very usual for a Korean person
video he would like you to college
student at college we will be treating
training in you know so he pulled up and
he asked me if I could I'm head for $80
in he has me they look like here well
they this customer he's got money like
the hotel but I couldn't pass up the
chats for just an extra $80 so I get in
the car and he drives me parks the car
I went to go down to give him head I was
enlightening fill up my eyes which is
like and I sat up and my head was
spinning as Sams he was bothering me in
the back of my head I have each bag lady
Samantha oh there was something there
and I pulled it out and it was a club a
hammer that it's done give me back my
head sure there's a club heart and she
stuck in the back of my head and I sat
up and I would say that I had this
hammer in my attic within within moments
the entire car was saturated with blood
we were slipping and sliding us but I
wanted to put the hammer down to fight
it but I was afraid he'd pick it up
start hitting me with it so I'm hitting
with his hammer and and he's fighting me
and all of a sudden he said he says to
be a get on a car and they didn't even
dawn on me before that point no I had I
was in joy yet it was in shock I had a
head trauma so but my thinking was no
I'm gonna die to make sure you know you
go with me and then I thought well maybe
I'm not gonna die maybe it's like yeah
there's car before I pass out I can live
I don't do that so I should sue canoes
have salmon I'll open my door open my
door so your bleens I wouldn't opens my
door and I fall out and I started
screaming help me help me the buildings
on my home fire and my babies in there
you know because if you just say help
lever yep but the building they might
might be there buildings on fire I'm
saying so so I stumbled out to the
street and I was covered in blood from
head to toe just sobbing with life and
attached to go turning right and I
hailed this taxi and he says to me oh oh
no you can't you know you get a car you
get a car
I call it fees where you give me a head
and I thought I just remembered I had a
boot knife in my boot at that moment and
so I pulled this knife out and stick it
in the store to just indigenous oh look
I said listen this is how it's gonna go
and I reached and I took that when I was
I threw it in this seat and I said
you're gonna drive me about five blocks
from here
and you're going to not say a word to
make me lose my faith in humanity any
further because if you do I'll just push
in with a prettier throat and worry
about how to get the car over later
I'm sure he's finally drove me over and
dropped me off and I got out I went to
this hotel and when I went in with my
customers saying was it a pepper class
kind of an individual says she's with
hospital all right yeah and I mix you
know I wake up my country and I'm in
this bed and he's taking everything
except for some dope I didn't and I took
me 45 minutes in the shower to get this
pillow it's time for my head because it
was stuck in the hole
okay sir no the pillow the pillow then
that the whole pill of it
your when I accepted the blood dried it
was you know I'm saying it and I could
just pull it because you know I'm a much
quite sure what's hail what's going on
so so I kind of shy of a forty-five
minutes did I get to be a pillow it
stuck my head and
you just put a little hat on I think
myself as cute as possible and angle at
work I had you out to worry because he
was now checkout time
checkout time 45 minutes prior to that
sure
[Music]
well I can't do it without my need one
I'm sorry I couldn't do that with
everybody right absolutely
so I'm Mike waters by Alvarado and I'm
the Stampede champ yeah I get the car
and he pays me and I go to give him yet
except for this time
very gently he went to touch the top of
my head and blood just all down my face
in his crotch him and he was screaming I
have a theory and yeah I gotta clean
myself up
so I yeah the car I apologize this man
doesn't keep the money he money go yeah
I gave him an I went like I clean myself
up a fire hydrant so I give me dollars
and I think I clean myself up and I go
back out because now I have to wear some
water so jackets buy some more clothes
and I saw a post and so this a homicide
detective comes driving down the street
and he pulls up and he says you know you
need to be really careful there's a man
out here killing him I go really does he
use a hammer and he's faced to regret
and he said what do you know about man
attacking one with a hammer and I turn
around like she's a little half of my
head I said because he hit me with her
and he says can you identify him I go
I've got his fingerprints would you like
the hammer he had wrapped it with gauze
and in the struggle of all the weapons
you kind of slid off and so his
fingerprints were really so I gave that
and then I put me in the car and took me
to the to the hospital drop me off
and the doctors said that I was really
really lucky the only reason I survived
with that confession was the hole in my
head released the pressure right I would
say we think for that
oh yeah they got an editing a pantsuit
he had driver's license but I didn't
have to
everybody testified any of them because
like with him there was so much there he
gave up the location they're like 14 my
body's so that they would take venue of
12 to take the death penalty after table
setting him like six thousand years
place for another so he'll never get out
there and the thing is I just had to
keep going on you know people go you
didn't just okay a hole in my head now I
like you just lay down and I mean oh I
have to just keep going I have to
persevere somehow I have to get forward
and that's right I had another one that
was in Chinatown Michelle Rainey a man
pick me up pick me up and he was a
manager of an apartment building on
Orange Street in Chinatown and I said
that was kind of strange I think you
know but shall we go into this apartment
building and it's about eight o'clock
the morning and we go up there and I
walk in the door every inch of the walls
he's covered in pictures of him and his
family and military gear you know in El
Salvador
you know Bennie Bennie pictures and you
know just all these different places
this is our new house and and so I said
okay so um he and she hands me a beer
and I go oh okay but I need my money
please he goes oh your money oh no you
get no money I mean
your life and your [ __ ] know you've
many a [ __ ] and your life I went like
this so I start screaming right cuz he
hits me the head with a bottle so I
start screaming I'm gonna die
everybody's gonna hear me die
so I'm screaming that people that beat
on the door like and he goes you can
scream all you want
I killed him all here nobody will help
you and my favorite he said you can
scream all you want
I killed them all here nobody's going to
help you
it might vary much and I just started
fighting right and I was on the he he
tackled me now this is a kind of a
squatty Stuckey kind of guy really
strong now he's he's got me on my back
okay and between a dresser and a bed and
I'm like a snow angel look I'm doing
this anything you'd get my hands on I'm
hitting with it and finally I got my
hands and he's got he's got his thumb by
my there accessible Mohammed are you
joking me out and so I finally get a
hold of bottle and I and I hit him and I
went oh that cut it from here to here
this face full flat flat for Rami and
but it's just pouring on me and we're
fighting were fighting he's still
fighting it his face is I don't know I
didn't have vertigo or something a bit I
guess the eyes didn't give I was just
just this the skin flat forward and I'm
coming a scalping but more like a facing
and we're fighting and finally he says
now I'm fighting for 24 minutes because
I'm looking at this digital clock on the
wall and it's like 24 minutes of
fighting like it's like professional
boxers don't even do that I was using
every molecule of my by my beings if I
survive listen finally he tells me check
it out well that sounded really good to
me yeah I get that but I run to the door
and I open the door and I turn I look at
he's coming at me with a machete not one
of those old the Cuban gonna whack a
piece of plenty half no this was a
techno green with this sharp wait I
guess she just glistening with sharp
nezam so I know where I'll be right
right now now Miss Julie which way which
way I think I won okay the other stairs
out the front door I'm now in Chinatown
again for whatever is that way right
right well I have a I have a basketball
throwback jersey shirt dress on there
was a very thick and it was ripped I
don't know how he ripped this but it was
ripped yeah I go out there and I'm
covered now again head you don't blood
hey help and no no busy busy every
really busy so I went to the corner to a
payphone when I pick up the phone and
I'm like I dial nine-one-one have the
answer of it I can't talk because I'm
just
my brains at overload and every time he
came around the corner I was like hey
because I don't know who's on my team
you know and so finally they uh they
they trace the phone to that firm and
they said that the paramedics over him
they pulled that box you the paramedic
truck and I ran over open the back door
championship with a guest wall and at
first there's this older black police
officer showed up and he wasn't very end
you know he was a very news that he had
to come kill ourselves and I said he
said can you identify him I remember she
twisted I spit out the room number and
he went up there when he came back he
was a completely different individual
towards me he was like sweetie it's
gonna be all right
they found they found me at least I was
a brother was a blood snow angel on the
floor from me trying to fight this guy
and all the blood it made this snow
angel on the floor and splattered bled
up against like wings up against before
ha and he said he took Peter took
pictures of that he said you won't have
to
you won't have to regret anything the
pictures alone I at first day their
doors they couldn't I was wrong with me
because they couldn't get me he couldn't
nothing brought me around no snotty
sauce inside out I was just out and I I
was fighting for 24 minutes with every
molecule of my being of course I was out
I am
there was no cracking my system now I
thought I was tired I was gonna go to
sleep you know so yeah that guy that guy
he killed six days off he's 26 6636 16
and 6 and
[Music]
how many people he's killed because you
killed my was the Asian I was 26
no and you what's really amazing is
you'll never hear about other news the
especially since it was the time the
personal news stories it was the
beginning of rejected vacation and they
were not going to hike rank occasions
their rings thank you
you know prison time yeah in $89.99
so share experiences
you're good clean I've had like eight
years in four years yeah one time your
side 35:13 ah did you recently know our
Asian food first couple years was like
and then my stepmother she she there's a
little story she raised him and he's
okay I haven't touched him a few guys
yeah
how much do you think your childhood
experience is like with your parents and
stepdad unfortunately you
the situation you're in today
unfortunately Matt great job even though
I know I should be a I mean I'm
intelligent really intelligence has
nothing to do with so I know and I know
you know textbook what Owens I thought
you know that we should I just can't see
really sir these cashews I wonder my
disorders I'm very emotional my crayons
dark bad
yeah started out trying to talk slow
yeah if I could speak as quickly as my
brain is functioning my hair would be a
[ __ ] fire and when we had the time
together was it better